slim lazy says i'll give you five pounds
right now if you can check me in 10.
okay i'll play one more challenge i'll
play the lowest rated player challenging
me
and i'll see if i can win in 10 moves
be this person right
probably this person
oh
i can't win this in 10 moves
oh i got tricked into playing another
game
i was trying to just fulfill this
challenge
so we're playing we're playing horde
chess
but there's a white king
which kind of changes things so in order
for me to win i have to mate
but it's still very similar
also white just hung up on because i
have three
things controlling that square
oh
oh slim lazy says give you 20 to be fair
wait 20 moves or 20
pounds
i don't even know what that currency
symbol is
it's going to take me 20 moves to just
capture most of the pawns
i don't know how to like execute a
mating attack here
uh i mean i have to try and open things
up as quickly as possible
[Music]
oh it's pounds ooh
i'll try i'll probably try and find a
normal chess game after this
yeah this isn't horde horde is played
with another rank of pawns and white
doesn't have a king
but this is like a horde version of
chess i guess
also what is my knight doing
i don't know why i played knight c6 i
just got kicked
i'll play this movie eric i sent you a
challenge and i have a low rating
unfortunately oh wait that's fortunate
for me though
okay
maybe i'll accept
but i have some business to take care of
before
we get to that
and this is really difficult
i have an idea though
yeah that's my idea
let's go
ah they found king d1 yeah kindy was a
good move
now it's gonna be hard to win now
i was really hoping to just intrude
break into the house steal the cookies
oh white's debating what to do
d4 yeah d4 is very
[Music]
logical have to be really careful here
this is three plus one
oh cabbage head is the longest word
yeah i think it's the longest word to be
to use like letters a through h
d3 is a good move
i'll play e6
just trying to chisel away
okay
ah this is kind of tough
i feel like i haven't really made
progress i have won a few pawns but
i so far i've lost a bishop in the night
and white's pawns are giving me
claustrophobia
oh cabbage hat is invalid
axor typo would know
axel typo would probably also know what
the longest word to use a through h is
hey it's a free pawn
oh de-headed the head cabbage head uh
that would be a difficult opening to
play
someday i can try i was waiting for this
baby also quack
oh thanks baby
how long do you plan playing eric she is
i am playing
it depends on the plan
um
i was not supposed to play another game
i was supposed to end the stream like
five minutes ago but
uh this this stream took an unexpected
turn
okay white's about to
suffer the consequences
of this position
there we go okay 27 moves it's not bad
thanks for the game
that was funny i accepted the lowest
rated challenge thinking it would be
normal chess
okay let's see let's try one more where
i have to win in ten moves
oh mallon miller is eight
eight eighty four okay i'll play malin
miller
swim lazy says
play one normal game if check made in 10
i gift five subs
can it be a nine
or in four
my pawn oh no
okay so within ten
ever played melon oh i have played melon
miller
the one time we played our game
was
52 moves long
ah this is gonna be tough
it's also tough when the opponent
might know what the challenge is
i have to play super aggressively here
ooh
i like seeing that move
how can i punish it to the
maximum maybe this move
okay we're on move five
like halfway there
i feel like i have to calculate now
so like calculate made in 10
you know this move
it's really close though
it's really close
i'm trying my best here
i don't know what white is going to do
because there's a lot of different
options
we need to
let's take this
wow
[Music]
it's move eight
it's move eight
wait it's my move eight so i basically
have three more moves
i don't know
it's not possible
[Music]
i'm probably just gonna give up
i'll set the board up for the next game
[Music]
i was really hoping for
a queen takes g4 i was gonna play bishop
f8 make it seem like a mouse slip
pre-move and then after it takes queen
d2 would be mate
but now yeah maiden 2 isn't even
possible from this position
or is it no it's not possible
or is it
i can't even conceptualize like mating
by move 10.
it seems close
okay i'll take
i'll still try and win as quickly as
possible
so this point i'll
i'm attempting to show no mercy
but it's going to take a bit longer than
10 moves
oh i just left my night hanging
i saw the queen attacking i just didn't
see the i did see the pawn attacking it
uh
okay
oh look at this pawn structure
the pawns were
gathering together
i'm so i'm a little bit salty though
eleven moves
i really tried
i'm back
five o'clock hey welcome back
oh the five o'clock
more like the 11 38 o'clock
a man did one in a video one eu
nf three north carolina six three north
carolina three b64 d4 bb75
d5 x56
x5 and 77 dc
okay we have to see what these north
carolinas mean
thank you melon miller
tim rosen good game also the other game
we played against each other was the
blindfold
i remember that
kind of
yeah it brings back memories
i think that's on youtube right
they're like a really long blindfold
slime game
yeah that was
that was mentally
taxing
um
wait let's see what uh how amanda did
this
so don jor says
does don dry say
oh monday then nine moves e4 e6
i have three knight c6
knight c3
e6 d4 bishop b7
yeah oh this looks nice already
i see what's coming
b6 takes
ah knight b5 g6 and some other mates
that's really nice
i have to learn from amman
oh thank you slim lazy
newest sub at tier one
yeah that's some consolation